in other videos we have talked about
that the type of element that we are
dealing with is defined by the number of
protons in an atom's nucleus so for
example any atom with exactly one proton
in its nucleus is by definition hydrogen
any atom with six protons in its nucleus
is by definition carbon
any atom with 17 protons in its nucleus
is by definition chlorine and so these
numbers that i'm circling on a periodic
table of elements that's known as the
atomic number but it's really just the
number of protons in an atom of that
element type's nucleus and that defines
what type of element it is
but in this video we're going to dig a
little bit deeper and realize that you
can still have different versions
of the same element and these versions
in chemistry speak are known as isotopes
now how can you have different versions
of the same element if the number of
protons defines what the element is
well the versions the various isotopes
are going to happen based on the number
of neutrons you have so for example
there are two stable isotopes of
chlorine there's one version of chlorine
known as chlorine 35. let me write it
over here chlorine 35 it's sometimes
written like this in fact it's often
written like this
chlorine
and this isotope notation that you see
over here where we have 35 in the top
left that 35 is a sum of this version
this isotope of chlorine's protons and
neutrons this number 35 is this isotope
of chlorine's mass number so it has a
total of 35 protons and neutrons how
many neutrons does this version of
chlorine have
well it's going to have 17 protons
17 protons i know that because we are
dealing with chlorine so how many
neutrons will have well 35 minus 17 is
18
18
neutrons
and there's another version of chlorine
that is stable and that is chlorine 37.
now how many protons is that going to
have
well that's a trick question by
definition it's chlorine it's going to
have 17 protons this is going to have 17
protons but then how many neutrons will
it have
well the protons plus the neutrons is 37
so 17 plus 20 is going to be 37 so it is
going to be 20
neutrons
and this would be written out as
chlorine
chlorine
37. so you can see these are two
different versions of chlorine same
number of protons which make them
chlorine but different number of
neutrons
now you can imagine these different
versions are going to have different
atomic masses
but here on a periodic table of elements
there's only one average atomic mass
listed and the key word here is this is
an average atomic mass it's the weighted
average of the masses of the chlorines
the stable chlorines that you will find
so for example in
nature
75
of the chlorine found is chlorine 35
and then the remaining
24.23
of the chlorine found is chlorine 37.
so when they calculate this average
atomic mass what they do is they would
take or you would take if you were
calculating it
so this would be
75.77
percent
times
the atomic mass
atomic
mass
of
chlorine 35
plus
and now the weight here would be
24.23 percent
times
the atomic mass
atomic
mass
of chlorine 37
and if you were to do this calculation
you would get this number right over
here 35.45
unified atomic mass units
now how do you figure out the atomic
mass of chlorine 35
you might be tempted to say it's just 35
unified atomic mass units and you would
be close because the mass of a proton is
close to
one universal atomic mass unit and the
mass of a neutron is close to one
universal atomic mass unit and then the
electrons are have a much much much
smaller mass you can also almost
consider them negligible for atomic mass
purposes
and so you will get an atomic mass close
to 35 but it actually turns out it's a
little bit different because not only
are the masses of each individual proton
or neutron a little bit more actually
than one unified atomic mass unit but
when you put all those protons and
neutrons together in a nucleus their
combined masses is actually a little bit
less than their individual masses if you
were to just add them up and that's
actually known as a mass defect and so
if you actually want to know the atomic
mass of chlorine 35 you can look that up
in a lot of tables and you will see that
it's actually slightly under 35 unified
atomic mass units